dos años de terror desde que un golpe
militar derrocó el gobierno encabezado
por la Premio Nobel de la paz a un
sansuchi mi amarse asumido en la
violencia según la relatoría especial de
Naciones Unidas la instalación de la
junta ha traído consigo 17.500 presos
políticos casi 3000 muertos la mayoría
en protestas más de un millón de
desplazados internos 70.000 personas que
han dejado el país y más de 17 millones
que requieren ayuda humanitaria
el pueblo de myanmar está bajo asalto no
de militares extranjeros que invaden sus
fronteras sino por lo que para ellos es
el equivalente a una potencia militar
ocupante que ha agredido sus derechos
humanos su democracia su gobierno es una
tragedia de inmensas proporciones
mientras los derechos de quienes
lideraban políticamente el país también
han sido vulnerados por ejemplo
recibió recientemente una condena de
siete años de prisión bajo acusación de
ese corrupción condena que si se suma
con anteriores fallos alcanzaría 33 años
de cárcel la cruente represión de la
junta incentivado que ciudadanos cree en
estructuras Rebeldes para oponerse al
régimen como la fuerza de defensa del
pueblo que combate con precarios
recursos
cuando el pueblo tenga un gobierno
electo descansaremos todos dejaremos la
Revolución y haremos los trabajos que
queríamos hacer hasta que llegue este
momento mantendremos nuestras armas
los rumores de que la junta plantea
convocar a elecciones este año no son
bien recibidos por organizaciones de
defensa de los Derechos Humanos
si la junta militar de myanmar sigue
adelante con las supuestas elecciones de
las que está hablando creo que eso
estimulará la violencia porque los
candidatos especialmente de los partidos
Pro militares serán vistos como un
objetivo por la fuerza de defensa del
pueblo
sometida 51 de los últimos 58 años bajo
el yugo militar myanmar sigue siendo un
desafío sin resolver para la comunidad
internacional